Traductor: Camila Klin
Revisor: Sebastian Betti
Este video dura 37 segundos.
Tan solo 37 segundos.
Estamos en Rosario, Argentina.
Es agosto del 2013.
Es la fuga de gas.
Una explosión, un derrumbe: 22 muertos.
Tal vez, la tragedia
más grande de Argentina.
Y yo solo pude grabar 37 segundos.
En ese momento no sé
por qué dejé de grabar.
Tal vez cuando pasó el tiempo
pude obtener algún tipo de respuesta.
Solo 37 segundos.
Uno, dos, tres, cuatro.
"Un periodista es una cámara con ojos
que sale de su lugar de comodidad
para ponerse incómodo".
Eso dice Leila Guerriero,
la gran cronista argentina.
Y es extraño, ¿no?
Los periodistas nos preparamos
toda una vida
para salir a contar algo
que todavía no ocurrió.
Y muchas veces son tragedias,
son momentos límite.
Esa mañana de agosto yo estaba en mi casa,
a seis o siete cuadras del lugar.
Escuché la explosión.
Estaba escribiendo.
Me movió unos 10 cm hacia atrás
Pensé que se podía haber caído
una viga de un edificio en construcción
enfrente de mi casa,
miré por la ventana: no vi nada.
Seguí escribiendo.
Hasta que empezaron a sonar las sirenas
de los bomberos y de las ambulancias.
En ese momento recibo una llamada de
la redacción de un medio de Buenos Aires.
Me preguntan qué es lo que estaba pasando.
Leo un tuit: el primer tuit
hablaba de una caldera,
de la explosión de una caldera.
Y yo tenía mi mochila preparada,
como siempre.
Una libreta para apuntes,
una cámara de fotos, un grabador.
Ese día iba a entrevistar al líder
de los Palmeras, justamente.
Daban un curso de cómo una banda de
cumbia se podía transformar en una pyme.
Y la realidad cambia así, abruptamente.
Empecé a caminar.
Cuando llegué a la calle Balcarce y Brown,
ahí a la altura del comedor Balcarce,
se veían los vidrios rotos,
y se me cortó la señal.
Quedé desconectado con ese medio.
Iba a hacer una cobertura,
sin saber para qué medio iba a trabajar.
Cuando llegué a Salta y Balcarce
todavía no había vallas,
había pasado hacía muy poquito tiempo.
Llegué a la esquina que
más caminé en mi vida.
Porque en mis épocas de estudiante
viví ahí, en ese edificio:
en Salta y Balcarce.
Los protagonistas de la tragedia
eran mis propios vecinos:
la rotisera, la farmacéutica.
Nunca había visto tanta gente
en estado de shock.
Yo mismo estaba en estado de shock
y perdí absolutamente la dimensión
de tiempo y de espacio.
No sé cuánto tiempo justamente pasó hasta
que logré obtener el primer testimonio.
Y era un testimonio de vida
en medio de tanta muerte.
Un colega me dice:
"ahí hay un sobreviviente".
Estaba con la mamá y con la novia.
Me acerco.
La novia me dice que soy un impertinente.
Tenía razón.
Eso hacemos los periodistas, ¿no?
Me retraigo hasta que Franco se acercó
y me contó parte de lo que había pasado.
Ahí descubrí la historia del hombre
que se despertó al borde del precipicio.
(Voz en off=
La madre y la novia de Franco
se mueven con el impulso
que empuja la desesperación.
Van y avanzan entre los cables cortados,
los vidrios rotos,
los ecos de un estruendo inaugural.
El panorama es desolador.
Los periodistas buscamos un número.
El número de muertos que nos dé
la magnitud real del ocaso.
Dicen 20, 30, 40, como
si la tragedia fuera una lotería.
Los familiares que corren
hasta Salta y Oroño
quieren ver, tocar y abrazar
a sus seres queridos.
Florencia y Eugenia no quieren que Franco
esté en la lista que
buscamos los periodistas.
Franco sale al borde
de un balcón que no existe.
Franco grita que está vivo porque vive.
En la lotería de la vida,
Franco solo tiene un manchón de sangre.
(Fin de la voz en off)
En las tragedias no hay moralejas.
En las tragedias no hay estereotipos:
no hay buenos, no hay malos.
Las tragedias son tautológicas.
Son tragedias.
Un año antes, en el 2012,
cuando se cumplía el aniversario
número 18 del atentado a la AMIA,
me había tocado investigar
sobre protocolos de rescate
porque quería contar
la historia de Alejandro,
un amigo, un triatleta.
En el triatlón hay valores.
En el triatlón se administra el dolor.
En el triatlón hay fe y hay resistencia.
Alejandro era mi compañero
en el triatlón allá por los 90,
cuando todavía no existían
las bebidas isotónicas
ni las zapatillas con cámara de aire.
Lo recuerdo siempre con una camiseta
que decía: "a muerte, triatlón".
Esa mañana de julio,
él era cadete en la AMIA,
llegó, se tomó el ascensor, como siempre,
y no sabía qué era lo que iba a pasar.
(Voz en off)
"Alejandro todavía no sabe que será
rescatado por los bomberos,
que su madre lo verá por televisión
sin reconocerlo,
que será trasladado de urgencia,
que estará alojado en la habitación 6115,
que sufrió fractura múltiple de tibia
y peroné en la pierna derecha,
que la poesía en la carta
ya se está escribiendo,
y que más allá del ascensor
y su terrible historia personal
afuera hay un verdadero infierno.
El ascensor no es el castigo divino:
es el comienzo del milagro.
Fue en otro abril, pero en el 95,
que Alejandro volvió a participar,
fue en el triatlón de Chascomús,
y durante la prueba
se deshizo de las muletas cuando
aún faltaban unos kilómetros para llegar.
No fue necesaria la música de Vangelis.
Alejandro volvió.
(Fin de la voz en off)
¿Por qué narramos
las historias que narramos?
Franco y Alejandro: dos nombres propios.
Franco y Alejandro: dos sobrevivientes.
A mi viejo, Roberto, que era médico de
pueblo en Colón, provincia de Buenos Aires,
le decían el doctor de los pobres:
Había más bicicletas en el consultorio
de mi viejo que en el hospital.
Así lo recuerdan.
Siempre me contaba una historia,
era un gran narrador de historias.
Él que estudió en la universidad pública
de Buenos Aires en le década del 50
compartió alguna jornada con el pediatra
Florencio Escardó.
Florencio Escardó tuvo una gran idea,
muy sencilla, pero muy innovadora:
En los hospitales, donde estaban las camas
de los niños, mandó a sacar los números,
y los reemplazó con los nombres
de los chicos.
Entonces ya no era el paciente
de la cama 1, 4, 5,
Eran Pedro, Lucía, José;
eran Franco, eran Alejandro.
Y nosotros en los medios hablamos de casos.
¿Cuántas veces nos falta ponerle nombres
a los protagonistas de nuestras historias?
En los medios hay ciertas verdades
absolutas que son incuestionables,
y se los digo yo que trabajé
en Crónica TV durante cuatro años
y a veces nos hacemos
preguntas innecesarias:
(Risas)
[¿Cuántos días faltan para la primavera?]
(Aplausos)
Y les quiero decir algo más:
Esas verdades absolutas son en nombre
de la audiencia, en nombre de Uds.
Hay una jactancia.
La gente quiere morbo, ¿no?
Necesitamos títulos que generen impacto.
¿Es así?
¿Pero quieren eso?
Pensemos que nos están escuchando
gerentes de medios.
¿Necesitamos ver un cadáver
en la tapa de un diario?
Nosotros, como cronistas,
cuando estamos en la calle,
muchas veces tenemos datos
que son muy escuetos.
Una vez me pasó que tenía un dato:
una persona muerta en un ajuste de cuentas
en la zona oeste de Rosario.
Cuando llegué al lugar
junto con mi camarógrafo, Carlos,
nos dimos cuenta que eso no era así:
era la historia de Mercedes Delgado,
una militante social
asesinada por balas narco.
Y cuando llegamos al centro comunitario
sus compañeras hicieron una pregunta:
¿Por qué vienen ahora?
Si acá nosotros jugamos con los niños,
les damos de comer,
incluso hasta toman la comunión,
pero vienen ahora.
¿Por qué los periodistas llegamos tarde?
(Voz en off)
Ahora hay banderines amarillos y blancos
que cuelgan de otra celebración.
Hay lágrimas y abrazos
que contienen el desgarro.
Hay oraciones con artículos,
balbuceos, impotencias, verbos en pasado.
Hay monjas, niños, obreros,
dirigentes gremiales, hijos y compañeras.
Hay carteles con dibujos y deseos
pegados en las paredes de cemento.
Hay canciones rezadas a viva voz.
Hay un ataúd cerrado
con una mujer muerta de dos tiros.
Hay una comunidad, un vecindario,
un grupo de mujeres, mamás,
militantes, malabaristas,
que hablan, susurran y alzan las palabras,
como pueden,
tratando de reconstruir
lo que ocurrió hace algunas horas:
el crimen de Mercedes Delgado.
Las historias no comienzan
cuando llega el narrador
y las historias continúan cuando
los narradores nos marchamos.
Como cronistas deberíamos llegar antes:
nunca la pude conocer a Mercedes Delgado.
Y tal vez deberíamos ser
los últimos en irnos.
Una vez estaba cubriendo una nota color:
así le llamamos en la tele
a aquellas noticias más pasatistas.
Había llegado una zorra...
Conocen este vehículo que sirve
para ir limpiando las vías, ¿no?
Y nosotros inaugurábamos un sistema
tecnológico de vanguardia en ese momento
que eran las cámaras 3G
con lo cual podíamos salir en vivo...
Esto que hacemos ahora con los celulares
todo el tiempo, ¿no?
En el medio de esa nota
mi hijo cumplía dos años, Bauti,
y aproveché para mandarle
un saludo en vivo y en directo.
Cuando llegué a mi casa le pregunté:
Bauti, ¿viste que papá
te saludó para el cumple?
Sí, papá, ¿y vos escuchaste
lo que yo te dije?
Claro, no lo había escuchado, ¿no?,
y no podía mentirle.
Al periodismo le hace falta
desarrollar más sentidos.
Necesitamos un periodismo
mucho más sensorial.
Varios años atrás, más de diez,
me tocó entrevistar
a un excombatiente de Malvinas.
Yo tenía la edad de mi hijo
cuando ocurrió Malvinas:
tenía ocho años.
En la entrevista me emocioné muchísimo.
Y cuando terminó, mi jefe me preguntó:
¿te emocionaste, no?
Sí, claro.
- ¿Tuviste ganas de abrazarlo?
- Sí
¿Y por qué no lo abrazaste?
Tal vez por la profesionalidad,
la objetividad periodística,
por mantener una equidistancia.
Tal vez al periodismo le haga falta esto:
más abrazos.
Pasaron muchos años de aquella entrevista
al ex-combatiente, otro sobreviviente,
hasta que ocurrió
la tragedia de calle Salta.
En el tercer o cuarto día también estaba
saliendo en vivo en un canal de televisión
y en un momento desplegaron
una bandera con dos palabras y un símbolo.
Las palabras eran:
gracias, bomberos, y un corazón.
En ese momento nos arrimamos hasta un bar
que funcionaba como centro de contención
y en la pared había leyendas, mensajes,
de chicos de la escuela primaria
para los bomberos y los rescatistas.
En ese momento pude leerlas en vivo
y darles un gran abrazo, tal vez el abrazo
que todo el país les quiso dar.
¿Por dónde empezar?
¿A quién preguntar algo?
¿Qué testimonio recoger?
En mis años de productor televisivo
tenía un jefe que a los periodistas quejosos
por cubrir notas de pequeño porte les decía:
No vas a tener una AMIA todos los días.
Esas son las notas fáciles de hacer,
donde encuadrás tenés una historia.
Mientras me acercaba más y más
al lugar del desastre recordé esa frase.
En cada rostro había
una historia por contar.
Esa adrenalina extraña que
segregamos los periodistas
en momentos extremos
me generó contradicciones.
El ocaso estaba en mi barrio,
mis vecinos eran los protagonistas.
¿Sabés qué te hubiera dicho tu ex-jefe?
¿Qué?
Ahí tenés tu AMIA.
Pero yo no quiero contar tragedias.
Necesitamos transformar el periodismo
en un periodismo más social.
Ya no nos alcanza con contar la realidad,
necesitamos modificar
esa realidad narrada,
necesitamos derribar
los muros de las redacciones,
necesitamos hacer periodismo con la gente.
De cada una de las personas,
los protagonistas de las historias,
siempre aprendí algo.
Como, por ejemplo, con las compañeras
de Mercedes Delgado,
con Alejandro,
con Franco,
con tu hijo Bautista,
con mi viejo y aquella historia
de Florencio Escardó.
De todos nos llevamos algo.
Ojalá alguna vez podamos revertir
desde el periodismo aquella pregunta:
¿por qué vienen ahora?
Y modificarla por un "gracias por venir".
Gracias por venir a todos Uds.
(Aplausos)